that's a lot of clocks Wow what
constitutes a lot is really a matter of
personal taste for me it's a perfect
amount of clocks oh sorry there's a
deranged cuckoo in there the ratchet
will shot at the quick Springs not far
behind hello
you're Luis I presume how was your trip
this old hag is my next door neighbor
mrs. Florence Zimmerman I'm relieved to
see you didn't inherit your uncle's
freakishly oversized head huh
says the woman who literally looks like
a q-tip oh look the giant head is angry
my god did that withered purple skeleton
just speak she thinks she's smarter than
me because she's got more college
degrees no I think I'm smarter than you
because I'm smarter than you
jack-o-lantern they scare away evil and
iron does too well it repels evil my bug
spray
and that is why we have iron horseshoes
and that's why cemetery gates are made
of iron and how does one become a
full-fledged warlock you have to defeat
an evil spirit by using your own magic
that is absolutely right what smells of
rancid sulfur
bhakti oh hello you look like the sort
of smart mind that could help me solve a
riddle now the answer is something that
you can find in this room you ready it
has many hearts but no brain and eight
kings and queens that rain what is it
[Music]
so should we just sit around and try to
figure out oh my giddy aunt
don't worry their teeth are made of
pumpkin they can't really hurt us you
only have to have dinner before I'm
allowed to have cookies well why not
just eat cookies for dinner they're far
more delicious
I know it's just we have these house
rules well not in this house
there's no bedtime bath time a meal time
you can eat cookies sell you throw up
for all I care
you'll see things are quite different
here do you like riddles me too now I've
got a really good one for you let's see
if you can find the answer in this room
behind me before time runs out I have
two hands but cannot clap a face but
never smile what am I
[Music]
outcome is doubled turn this draw sled
into gold
wow that was really really terrible I
mean just awful you're reading it like
it's a Buick manual it's not what you
say Louis it's how you say it you're the
only you in the whole universe that
makes your style of magic just crazy
unique one in a hundred million
kajillion so i can give you the right
books teach you the right spells but
that last one percent that's up to you
so how do I find my magic style or
whatever it is it's in there somewhere
I just have to quiet down and listen now
it looks like you're pooping today our
National Book Day I challenge you I
challenge you to pick up that book that
you've been putting on and discover some
new magical powers of your own a bump in
the night Louis slid out of bed as
slowly and carefully as he could he
tiptoed to the door he opened it just as
slowly and carefully he looked out the
hall was dark except for a faint pale
circle of a flashlight being moving over
the wallpaper now the figure with the
flashlight brought his fist down on the
wall hard
Louis heard little clots of plaster
falling down into space between the wars
the figure pounded again and again and
again
what is he some real magic I'll show you
laughs stop
Louis I'm your uncle Jonathan are you
wearing a robe it's a kimono here we are
home sweet home
[Music]
you're Luis I presume how was your trip
this old hag is my neighbor I'm relieved
to see you didn't inherit your uncle's
freakishly oversized head my God did
that withered purple skeleton just speak
you'll see it's quite different here
have a look around you're perfectly safe
safe as long as it's fed do you know
what a warlock is Lois a boy which I
think they're a little more than boy
widgets are you seeing that you're a
warlock
please teach me please please okay have
it your way I can give you the right
books teach you the right spells that
last 1% that's up to you
I don't want the creepy little runt sink
I wanted lucky shot
you've told Lois everything not
everything this house used to be owned
by another warlock he's very wicked very
powerful he left a hidden clock in the
walls we don't know what it does except
something horrible three gums last time
it was for what happens when it gets
down to one nothing good that's for
certain
we have to destroy the clock
so creepy you can't do this alone I can
help you
once these real magic I'll show you
shall we
sorry punky hello
you're Lewis I presume
[Music]
[Applause]
you'll say things are quite different
here
[Music]
[Music]
the house is a very old place
[Applause]
there's a clock in the walls
we don't know what it does except
something horrible
so you told Luis everything well not
everything
[Music]
[Music]
have a look around you're perfectly safe
that's safe as long as it's fed
[Music]